here with reaction is Victor Davis
Hansen of the Hoover Institute all right
you want to give a a crack at
interpreting this new economic uh
Paradigm that Obama's talking about is
this like Joe the plumber kind of
Economics spread the we yeah it is I
think everybody realizes yeah the last
year of the Obama Administration he more
or less checked out during the Clinton
Trump race and I feel he feels now that
this would have been his third term and
he could have been a lot more leftwing
and he feels sort of regretful that
people say you know you signed a $150
million book deal Netflix you've got
four mansions Martha's Vineyard Hawaii
colorama you've kind of sold out Barack
and now he wants to get back into the
game and he's got a great opportunity
because Joe Biden is cognitively
challenged and he's trying to push a
more radical agenda than he felt uh he
could during his own presidency and it's
kind of ironic though Sean with all of
these mans
and was Michelle making $122,000 a
minute speaking in Germany and remember
Barack is pro the both of them are
probably worth a half a billion dollars
and then to talk about uh re rejection
of material consumption or a more
inclusive capitalism does that mean to
give up one of his Mansions or you know
say I don't need a Hawaii beach home and
a marth's Vineyard beach home so wait a
minute but Victor opportun he's such a
hypocrit when illegal immigrants went up
to his new
HomeTown uh my understanding is they
were kicked out of the off the island in
less than 24 hours uh I understand he
has 12 acres couldn't he have put them
up
there yeah well we know that utopian Le
have one cardinal rule Sean that yeah
one Cardinal Ru they're never subject to
the disastrous consequences of their own
ideology it always falls on distant
others and that's true of the Obamas
that his great gift to us we're watching
unfold in the Middle East it's the Shia
Crescent idea of empowering Iran
Damascus Beirut Hamas balance it against
the Israelis and our friends in the gulf
and that was supposed to make creative
tension and you saw what happened it
blew up the Middle East his idea about U
ukra Uh Russian reset remember that from
2009 to 2014 that gave us the Ukrainian
War the Invasion earlier of Crimea and
Ukraine and then the latest Invasion
based on that appeasement so he's
looking at this record and it was a
disaster and now he feels he can get
back into the game because of Joe's sort
of non-c compos menst to be frank and
he's going to use that vacuum but always
in the shadows he said to a Sean when he
was interviewed once what was his dream
presidency and he said to be away from
the hard work and just phone it in from
his basement Obama said that so I think
this is the ideal situ ation he's always
hoped for to be kind of the Puppeteer
and have Joe the puppet it looks like uh
Joe achieved Obama's dream anyway uh the
great Victor Davis Hansen thank you my
friend hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else